jose or kitty is on the boundary on
darling and this is a guy with some
pedigrees only 25 years of age but he's
pitched in some big moments and he's got
a big start here tonight for houston big
moments and lots of experience 18 and
two-thirds innings he's been on that
mound he really has to take the
blueprint from the colors yesterday he
has to have that change up poorly
working early and often brandon lau will
stand in the second baseman wow lifts
this one pretty deep to left center on
his horse springer once again on the
edge of the warning track makes the
catch onto the warning track and that's
a one two three inning for jose or
keaney one out of no one on for altuve
three for nine this postseason or this
uh league championship series has a home
run
which he hit in game one and altuve
drives this pretty deep in the left
field going back to rosawaina at the
wall and that ball is gone into the
first row for jose altuve his second
home run of the alcs and the astros lead
one to nothing pitch at the letters for
altuve and he turned on it really quick
hands
only altuve a second home run off a
lefty in 2020. he hit one off madison
bumgarner back on august 4th in arizona
tied with george for post-season homers
now at 17. now comes alex bregman
gregman swings and sends one deep in the
air to straight away center keermeyer
heading back to the warning track he's
back on the wall jumps up and he
did he get it yes he did side retired
bregman testing the limits but kier
meyer measuring his
leap and was able to get it right at the
wall i don't know if it would have gone
over or not but it certainly was hit
well enough for an extra base head and
the rays have loaded the base perez
getting his first start of the alcs over
mike's and nino sway gonna foul tip into
the glove of the catcher garneau and
perez goes down on a change-up and the
rays leave him loaded there's two away
runner goes over to third here's diaz
flew out to right his last time up that
ball rifled to right field and that is
caught by tucker and
urkidi strands another runner in scoring
position bregman's going to take first
and now to second goes bradley and
here's correa lift in the shallow center
kiermaier coming on can he get there
dives and makes the catch
kevin keermeyer with another run-saving
grab this one in right center field as
he takes away a base hit from correa and
he strands a couple of more houston
astro base runners in a one to nothing
houston league courtesy of this man jose
altuve's home run just sneaked over the
left field wall swinging the ground ball
left side into the hole adamus has it
the off balance throat want to bounce
diaz has it he's out at first side
retired and willie may not be hitting
that much this october but boy his glove
has shown up and is taking center stage
another fine play by william four hits
for the raise he has two of them the
others belong to joey wendell
and manuel mergo and it's time for
brandon lau to join
the hit party curveball and that's
grounded right side to altuve throws the
second on the hop and it gets past
correa and kicks into left field
stopping at second arose arena and jose
altuve who did not commit a throwing
error during the regular season commits
his third throwing error in the last two
games that's a shame should have been a
double play it is bases loaded nobody
out and joey wendell the hitter and
paradise to the belt swing line drive
off of fragment it goes into left for a
base hit a rose arena scores lau heads
for the play that he will score wendell
has delivered the rays have a 2-1 lead
well what we're seeing that the rays do
is take advantage of the astros mistakes
again nothing into the count and it hit
him came up and in and hit him on an o2
pitch
and the bases are loaded kiermeier is
holding on to his left hand as he traps
towards first base that got him in a
very vulnerable spot
that's not good he's going to stay in
well he's going to stay in the run we've
seen kevin do this before though where
he's gotten hit base his little
situation has found willie adams and
that one hit him too willie says it did
and so does home plate umpire jeff
nelson it's a hit by pitch and a run
batted in the rays have a three to one
lead glad i heard something get ticked
and it was not
the bat renfro to bat
rayleigh to pitch
and the raise with base runners
everywhere wendell at third kirimeyer at
second still and willian thomas at first
here it comes swinging he pops him up
foul first base side dropping fair or
fouled it lands a fair ball here comes
wendell in the score here comes carr
meyer to score to third base adams he
holds it's a bloop double for hunter
renfro and the rays have a 5-1 lead well
he mishit it
but he hit it where they ain't now
tucker was playing way over toward the
gap in right center field
and a miss hit that just blooped in and
dropped about 10 feet fair kim i are
going to go get some treatment on that
wrist it looks like x-ray ryan yarbrough
still on the mound his first pitch to
michael brantley is lifted to left and
deep it sends back a rose arena at the
wall and that ball is gone
michael bradley goes deep for the third
time this postseason and it is five to
two tampa bay brantley saying hold on
boys we're not done yet the astros have
plenty of life left and plenty of outs
left in this ball game curtis ready to
go to work and you're the guriel the
better swung out and grounded to the
left for the mound curtis dives gets it
now from his knees gets up fires the
first and got him what a defensive play
by the pitcher
everybody knows how to throw the leather
around for the raise one out when do you
ever see a pitcher dive
i mean curtis back into that thing
pretty far off the left side of the
mound reddick leads it first the pitch
to springer swinging a line drive to
right field renfro coming in and over to
his left dives and he makes the catch oh
my what a grab by hunter rent throwing
right to take away extra bases from
george springer and end the houston
seven three of loop's appearances he's
faced the man coming to the plate now
kyle tucker tucker representing the
go-ahead run swing and a looper into
right field coming on his red throw
he'll slide and make the catch
so tucker flies to right another fine
grab
by retro as he was able to track that
one so there's two outs and now here's
julie guriel and a guy that a year ago
you never wanted to see in this spot
swinging a ground ball towards short
willie has it his throw to first is in
time and the rays get out of it again
the astros leave him loaded in the
eighth one more time now castillo's
ready to go a one ball two strike pitch
check swing and strength three says home
plate umpire jeff nelson
maybe it was a called strike three
either way he is gone they didn't ask
for an appeal and altoona is retired and
the raiser in out away and the astros
are down to their final out michael
brantley he is the tying run optim in
the air left center field playable
margot moving to his right he is there
the rays have won game three
they have taken the first three games of
the league championship series and they
are one win away from the world series